Hi, everybody.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show
At Home Edition."
Guys, we had some
great news yesterday.
Our friends over at State Farm
said they will match
up to $100,000 of donations.
So, if you're
on YouTube right now,
click that button, donate
to redcross.org/statefarm.
Our neighbors
over at State Farm,
thank you, thank you so much,
for doing this.
It's the coolest thing
and I just love how everyone's
just helping out.
It's just really amazing.
Speaking of helping out,
I wanted to say,
we talked yesterday
about Steve Higgins' daughter.
Anna Higgins is a nurse
and we thanked her
for all she does,
but, to every nurse out there,
I really wanna say
thank you so much
for what you're doing.
You guys are on the front lines
and the doctors as well.
You're heroes, so,
thank you, guys, so much.
We have a fun show tonight.
My pal, my BFF,
Demi Lovato is on the show.
What?!
She is the greatest.
We're gonna talk to her.
We're gonna have
a little art class,
a little painting lesson,
with Demi.
She's been doing
a lotta painting
and I'm gonna try
a self-portrait with her.
And then, she's gonna sing
her new song,
"I Love Me,"
to close out the show tonight.
And it's a beautiful song
with a great message
and she can do it all.
She's great.
Also, I have Jonathan Van Ness
is on the show.
He has a children's book called
"Peanut Goes for the Gold"
and it is about a...
nonbinary guinea pig
who wants to win the gold medal
in rhythmic gymnastics.
So, it's one of those books.
"Oh, seen that one before,
yeah, obviously."
[chuckle]
It's so great to talk to him
and we'll find out
their charities,
which we have right here,
actually.
This is Demi Lovato's charity.
Winnie wrote this out. We'll
-Mm.
-maybe do a chyron for ya
so you can see.
#cut50.
It's a petition for you to sign,
basically,
raising awareness for prisoners
and people incarcerated
that need help
during this time as well.
A little criminal justice there.
And then, right here, this is
aliforneycenter.org.
And this is more
of a New York, local charity
that Jonathan will talk
about later in the show.
But I appreciate it.
Guys, let's do
a little monologue.
We did it yesterday
from the lemonade stand,
so, now, we graduate
and we have a real, actual,
working desk.
Look how exciting this is.
Wow.
So. It's a little rickety,
but this is it right here.
My camera operator is my wife.
Nancy, I love you so much.
If you want to,
you can zoom in a little bit.
Gary, I guess you wanna
come in, too.
Okay.
-Hi, Gar.
-Gary, you wanna be a guest?
-Higgins.
-C'mere, Gar.
[snaps fingers]
-[Laughs]
[ Thud ]
Good girl. Alright.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show,"
everybody.
"At Home Edition."
It's a fun day in our house
'cause I decided to cook up
a real special meal.
[ Smoke alarm beeping ]
Welcome to "The Tonight Show
At Home Edition."
It's a fun day in our house
'cause it's pizza night!
What a show we have
for you guys.
Demi Lovato
and Jonathan Van Ness
are my guests tonight
and who knows?
Maybe the My Pillow guy will
drop in for no reason at all.
Did you see that yet, honey?
Oh, yeah.
I saw it, too.
Let's get to some news.
A Navy hospital ship
has arrived in New York
because, if there's one thing
we've learned from the crisis,
it's that you definitely want
to be on a giant ship.
Well, this is nice.
Last night,
the Empire State Building
was lit up in red-and-white
flashing lights
to honor healthcare workers.
When they saw that,
New Yorkers were like,
"That's great.
Maybe next time,
could you give us a heads up?!"
What?! I thought we were being
invaded by North Korea!
The flash-- I didn't even
know it could do that!
[ Laughing ]
Gosh! Warn me.
Warn me, folks.
Yep, everyone was confused
by the red-and-white
flashing lights.
At first, New Yorkers
thought it meant
Target finally got a shipment
[laughing] of toilet paper.
I saw that there's
a Microsoft Excel
training program
now available for $49.99.
Yep, I'm "three weeks
of isolation" bored,
but I'm not quite "Microsoft
Excel training" bored.
This year, you can order --
I saw, this year, you can order
Girl Scout Cookies online.
That's awesome.
And, to give you
the real experience,
after you buy two boxes,
a Girl Scout pops up onscreen
and guilts you
into buying two more.
[ Laughs ]
-[Chuckle]
-I guess.
What's another box of
[Southern accent] Thin Mints?!
Gimme a Thin Mint!
[own accent] I heard people
have been passing the time
by stress baking,
which is just like regular
baking, except, when it's done,
you eat all of it
over the sink.
[ Laughing ]
And, finally, in Australia,
an astrophysicist got magnets
stuck up his nose
while trying to invent a device
to stop people
from touching their faces.
That story again.
Hey, Winnie and Frannie,
you both have what it takes
to be astrophysicists!
-[Laughing]
-And that's our monologue
for tonight.
Guys, you've been sending in
great questions called
#AskTheFallons,
and questions you wanna
ask my wife, Nancy;
or my daughters,
Winnie and Frannie.
So, we went for a social
distancing walk today
and had a couple
nice discussions.
Please enjoy.
Okay, so this is
interview number 2.
Are those my sunglasses?
-No.
Yes, I only own
your sunglasses.
-Isn't it funny?
Sometimes we don't even
practice it or whatever,
talk about it, plan it, but we
wear the same things sometimes.
Stripey shirt or...
-Yeah.
Or like Navy sweaters.
[ Laughter ]
We're looking like we're
getting ready for a bad,
-Yeah.
-awkward, family portrait.
-Yep.
-How's homeschooling,
by the way?
It's been fun.
-Oh, my gosh.
[gasp] Here comes a van.
Don't say anything.
-[Laughs]
-But we're gonna wave.
Hi!
Homeschooling?
These teachers are brilliant.
-Amazing.
-Devoted, loyal.
They are just going
so out of their way
to make this okay
for those of us
[laughing] who do not know
what we're doing.
Raising hand high.
And we're getting through it.
Here we go.
-Are you getting better
at Zoom?
-I am getting -ish.
I still fight it,
but I keep saying,
about this whole virus thing,
"Stop fighting it.
Stop fighting the change.
Stop fighting the new
way of life, for now.
Just go with it and I think
will help you mentally."
-Okay, these are questions
people wanna know
or wanted me to ask you.
-Okay.
-"What's your favorite
memory with Gary?"
This is from @prockj.
-My most favorite memory
with Gary was...
[ Laughter ]
-It's not the delivery.
-Yes! Of course!
The first memory is my
favorite memory with Gary.
Gary was a complete surprise!
And --
-By the way, guys --
and girls,
-Yes.
-whoever's watching.
If you're gonna get
a surprise for your wife,
don't get her a dog 'cause
it's like getting her
a job, really.
-It was another job.
-[Laughs]
-But I love Gary --
-Is that why you were crying?
-No.
[laughing] I really cried
because I couldn't believe
she was so beautiful
and perfect and so cute.
And I just couldn't
even believe it.
But then, of course,
I probably started bawling,
trying to think of,
"What do we have?
I need to take care of her.
Where does she sleep?
[singsong] What's the plan?
What's the plan?!"
Ugh! She's the best.
She's part of the family.
-[Laughing]
-She's also very loyal.
I was thinking about the time --
-And loving.
-Remember when --
[ Laughter ]
We were having a party.
I wanna say
it was Thanksgiving
-Oh, no.
-or Winnie --
Frannie's birthday
or something
and everyone was upstairs
with your dad
and your dad had the walker
and you were trying
to get your dad safely
[ Laughter ]
to the elevator
so that he can leave.
-Ugh!
But then, someone had Gary
on a leash
because we didn't wanna
bring Gary to the party
or something. We kept her
-Because Gary's
-in a separate room.
-a bit of a jumper.
-Yeah. So we --
-Only on people who
don't wanna be jumped on.
-But then what happened?
The leash got caught
in the walker?
[ Laughing ]
[ Laughter ]
-Tangled into the walker.
-Tangled into the walker
and just started doing spinouts.
-And my dad is yelling,
"[muttering]"
and then everyone, of course,
-Trying to hold the dad.
-all the women around dad,
trying to hold him, are all
-The dog is
-yelling and screaming.
-squealing
and everyone's --
-Gary made sounds,
for the first time,
she usually doesn't
and blah, blah, blah.
-That was a Gary memory.
-Hi!
-Hello.
-Hey, guys.
-How you guys doin'?
-Beautiful baby.
-Thank you! This is Jake.
-Thanks so much.
-Aw. Bye, Jake.
Ooh. Nancy, this is
from @GirlySunglasses.
-Ooh! Oh, I just took
my sunglasses off.
-"Nancy, what did you
think of Jimmy
when you first met him
on the set of 'Fever Pitch'?"
Which is --
-I thought -- I first met Jimmy,
actually, on "SNL."
And I'd gone in --
I'm producing partners
with Drew Barrymore
and she was on the show
that week.
-I remember that.
-And she and Jimmy
were practicing a sketch
and I went in and I kind of
crept in quietly
and, all of a sudden,
[laughs] Jimmy goes,
"Hey! Nancy!
You're Nancy? Hi!
It's so nice to meet you!
Welcome!"
And I felt just so embraced
and like cool, like,
"Thank you!
Thank you for welcoming me in.
This is so nice.
It's so intimidating."
So, I had that thought,
from years before, going in.
And then --
-'Cause it can be
intimidating, if you go
to "Saturday Night Live,"
don't know anybody.
-Ugh! So intimidating.
And I had no real reason
to be there.
I was sort of like meeting her
to go somewhere or something.
Anyway, so, but then,
on the set,
we were on location
and that really creates
this like camp feel
for everybody and --
-Hello.
-Hi.
-Hey.
-And he was just
so friendly and fun!
And welcoming
and he loved music.
And then, when I really
developed a crush
was when Bradley Thomas'
kids came to set
and he had a little girl
named Lucy
and a little boy named Charlie.
And I played with Lucy
and Jimmy played with Charlie
and really played,
like really into it,
as if they'd come to visit us.
And so I think that's
when my heart just sort of
melted
[Southern accent] even more.
-Aw.
I remember those kids.
Oh, they were so cute.
-Yeah.
They're like teenagers, now,
or in college, probably.
-I remember when I first
experienced the magic that is
[chuckle] Nancy Juvonen.
We were on the set,
but we were filming
"Fever Pitch" in Boston
-Yeah.
-and it was a rainy,
gray, Bostony day.
-Yep.
-And you came to set.
And you --
-I walked to set.
That was the first day
of shooting.
-Yeah.
And you walked to set
and I wanna say
you had white pants,
-Yes.
-a pink sweater...
-[Laughing]
-...and a green backpack?
-Yeah, my
green Jansport backpack...
[ Laughter ]
...that I think I'd had
since college.
-And blond hair
and your white teeth.
And I was like you just stood
out in this gray --
It was almost like a painting.
And you stood out like a neon --
And I was like, "Uh, wow.
She is," yeah.
You just stuck out.
And you were just so fun.
We had so much fun
on that movie, didn't we?
-Yeah. We had so much fun,
And we got to just
sort of flirt and hang out
and get to know each other,
without having to go on a date
or anything like that.
-No.
-For months!
We just got to be pals.
-Yeah.
-And have crushes,
which is so hard and so fun,
and it shouldn't just be
limited to high school.
-Right?
-It's so fun to have
to kind of wait and just like,
"Oo-oo-ooh!
What should I wear
[singsong] today?
Is he gonna be on set early?
What's gonna happen?
[ Laughter ]
Is he shooting today?"
-Yeah. But we got to know each
other's musical taste and --
-Yeah, and then,
when the show ended,
we weren't sure, like,
"Maybe this is nothing.
Maybe this is just
a cute little flirt."
And I'm like, "He's probably
dating like 30 women.
I don't know."
I know now how funny that is,
but, at the time, I didn't know.
[ Laughter ]
-Gosh! Dating 30 women?
Oh, my God.
-I don't know what people do.
-I know.
I'm like Pete the Pilot.
-Yeah.
Totally were The Bachelor.
And then, you know, I'm sure he
didn't know what I was up to.
-Yeah.
-And then, when we saw
each other again...
-In London.
-We were selling the movie.
-To sell the movie.
-I was like, "Hey!
I miss you.
I wanna hang out with you."
-Mm-hmm.
-And then, you said
you missed me, too.
[ Laughter ]
Corny. This is gonna be
the corniest video
that anybody's ever seen.
Alright, that's enough
#AskTheFallons for now, right?
-It's a good session, I think.
-It's a good session.
[ Laughter ]
It's a good session.
We'll be right back, everybody.
-Bye!